après avoir vécu au centre de l'histoire
de l'aéropostale toulouse vit désormais
au rythme de l'aérospatiale nouvelle
illustration avec l'ouverture de la cité
de l'espace
un parc de 5 hectares qu'il faut visiter
pour tout savoir et pour tout comprendre
sur l'espace muriel la saga dit lopez
elle planète pas tout à fait comme les
autres
en quelques mois la cité de l'espace a
surgi de terre avec pour étendard la
réplique grandeur nature du lanceur
ariane 5
une apparition dans le ciel toulousain
qui a très vite attiré une constellation
de curieux parmi eux johan sept ans un
petit toulouse ans déjà très au fait de
l'actualité spatiale tu connais déjà
certaines choses sur les freins comme
quoi pas répondre
les petits lézards qu'elle avait pris
claudia mre des allées fleurot d'elle
que de la route d'al aroui yoann a même
réussi à poser le pied sur la lune
pas toujours convaincant
ou pas trop nous et qui est system
système solaire et tout ce qui est au
niveau des étoiles vous prenez j'ai pas
du tout pensé quoi revirement aurait
certainement simulateur les bornes
interactives entraîne le visiteur dans
cet univers parfois mystérieux côté
pratique on peut arrimer un vaisseau
spatial à une station orbitale ou encore
voyager dans les étoiles pour réaliser
un ensemble comme celui ci qui
représente toutes les missions spatiales
au grand public
il faut quand même avoir un peu les
pieds sur terre le présenter avec 170
éléments d'exposition
ce parc aura coûté 4 millions de francs
le prix à payer pour atteindre
l'inaccessible étoile